Comme je le disais, nous avons fini le chapitre 5, nous allons aborder le chapitre 6,
cette prédication sera l'introduction au chapitre 6,
et nous allons nous concentrer essentiellement sur les versets 1 au verset 7.
Ce que je voudrais introduire avant, nous avons pu lire,
peut-être qu'il y a des personnes qui ont peut-être écouté Ézéchiel pour la première fois,
si nous avons un invité qui a pu entendre un passage,
ou même peut-être dans l'assemblée, c'est la première fois que tu entends Ézéchiel chapitre 6,
et que tu peux être choqué par tout ce que tu viens d'entendre,
et de te demander si, surtout quand on a une mauvaise conception de Dieu,
on va se dire, mais si Dieu est bon, comment toutes ces choses peuvent être prononcées ?
Mais il y a toujours des choses que nous devons garder dans notre esprit.
Il est très important de garder à l'esprit que, surtout sous les livres de l'Ancien Testament,
que chacun des livres de l'Ancien Testament fait partie du filigrane
qui nous permet de comprendre l'Évangile.
C'est très important.
L'Évangile est pleinement révélé dans le Nouveau Testament
parce que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ arrive enfin,
et ensuite les apôtres qui ont vécu, ou bien ceux qui ont pu être témoins,
vont transmettre ce qu'il a partagé.
Mais avant, dans l'Ancien Testament, nous devons comprendre que l'Ancien Testament
fait partie de l'Évangile.
On a souvent tendance, certaines personnes ont tendance à séparer l'Ancien Testament
et leur compréhension de Dieu.
C'est un Dieu de colère, c'est un Dieu injuste,
et dans le Nouveau Testament, ce Dieu est devenu gentil.
Ce n'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne.
L'Évangile, c'est l'Ancien et le Nouveau Testament.
Nous l'avons même chanté ce matin,
ce rappel, et qu'est-ce que la Bible nous rappelle,
déjà même dès l'Ancien Testament,
c'est que la parole de Dieu nous rappelle à un moment que c'est Dieu
qui a créé le monde et tout ce qu'il contient.
C'est Dieu qui a créé tout ce que nous pouvons observer dans la nature.
Et quand Dieu a créé les choses,
toutes ces choses étaient parfaites.
C'est difficile à imaginer pour nous aujourd'hui,
parce que nous sommes dans un monde qui est touché par le péché,
qui est touché par les conséquences du péché.
Et d'ailleurs, nous avons même ces expressions populaires à un moment,
de même dire à un moment,
personne ici-bas n'est parfait.
Parce que nous sommes conscients à un moment
que le péché est ancré dans la vie de chacun de nous.
Mais ce n'était pas comme ça avant.
Dieu avait créé l'homme et la femme,
il les avait placés dans le jardin d'Éden
avec l'autorité sur toute la création.
L'homme et la femme ont désobéi à Dieu,
et non seulement leur péché les a affectés,
mais le péché a affecté l'ensemble de la création.
Dieu les a chassés du jardin,
ils ont perdu la communion avec Dieu.
Mais même dans cette promesse,
quand Dieu est en train de punir le serpent qui les a trompés,
Dieu fait cette promesse à un moment,
que la postérité de la femme écrasera la tête
de la postérité du serpent et lui blessera le talon.
Dieu se choisit et quand Dieu fait ça,
Dieu décide, comme l'homme Adam avait échoué dans cette première tâche,
Dieu décide d'accomplir un plan
pour pouvoir nous restaurer,
pour pouvoir nous délivrer de l'emprise du péché.
Abraham est ce point de départ.
Et Dieu promet à Abraham d'être le père d'une multitude.
Et Dieu lui donne une promesse à un moment,
lui disant, ce peuple, je vais te donner,
tu seras le père d'un peuple nombreux.
Et à un moment, ils seront même déportés,
ils iront en Égypte,
ils seront faits esclaves en Égypte,
mais ensuite je les délivrerai.
Et donc Dieu a accompli cette promesse.
Quatre siècles plus tard,
Dieu a libéré le peuple d'Israël d'Égypte,
et les a emmenés dans la terre promise,
cette terre qu'il avait déjà promise à Abraham,
Isaac et Jacob.
Et au moment de rentrer dans la terre promise,
Dieu traite une alliance avec le peuple.
Dieu traite une alliance avec le peuple
où si le peuple s'engage à obéir à Dieu,
il leur montre toutes les bénédictions
qui seront attachées si le peuple lui obéit.
Mais si le peuple n'obéit pas,
Dieu leur rappelle un moment
quels seront les jugements
qui tomberont sur eux.
C'est très important.
Là, je vous rappelle un peu le contexte.
Et nous revenons maintenant au texte d'Ézéchiel.
Ce qui se passe,
c'est que quand Dieu établit le peuple,
après plusieurs siècles de patience,
Israël va honorer l'alliance à certains moments.
Israël va se détacher de l'alliance
qu'ils avaient conclue avec Dieu.
Et cette alliance, c'était que Dieu soit leur seul Dieu.
Alors, c'était nouveau.
C'était assez bizarre à l'époque
puisque toutes les nations autour d'Israël
avaient plusieurs dieux.
Ils avaient des dieux locaux.
Ils adoraient même les dieux étrangers.
Et Dieu dit à un moment à Israël,
je serai votre dieu exclusif.
Vous n'aurez pas d'autres dieux.
Je serai le seul dieu.
Vous ne vous ferez pas d'autres des idoles
devant ma face.
Et Israël n'a pas respecté cet engagement.
Et lorsque nous arrivons à ce texte d'Ézéchiel,
ce texte d'Ézéchiel est juste la conséquence
de ce que Dieu,
les choses sur lesquelles Dieu avait mis en garde Israël,
s'il n'obéissait pas.
Et nous l'avons vu,
nous avons abordé beaucoup d'aspects
lors du chapitre 5,
sur la dernière partie que nous avons faite
dernièrement sur la prédication il y a deux semaines.
Nous voyons à un moment que Dieu exécutait ses jugements
parce qu'Israël avait commis le péché d'idolâtrie.
Le péché d'idolâtrie,
c'était le fait que quand Dieu établissait
l'alliance avec Israël,
il leur avait dit,
je serai votre dieu,
votre seul dieu,
et ils devaient s'engager à l'aimer
de tout leur cœur,
de toute leur âme,
de toute leur force.
C'est-à-dire que tout leur être
devait être engagé à aimer le Seigneur.
Et même dans l'expression physique,
cet amour envers Dieu voulait dire
que Dieu ne devait pas être représenté
sous une forme d'idole,
de bois ou de quelconque.
Mais Israël n'a pas obéi à cela.
Et donc le jugement qui est annoncé,
que nous avons lu dans ce chapitre 6,
ce jugement était annoncé,
ce jugement apportait,
c'est ce que la parole dit,
apportait l'opprobre et la honte.
Et ce jugement servait à signaler
combien Israël,
combien le péché d'idolâtrie
avait des conséquences horribles
aux yeux de Dieu.
À cause du fait que Israël
n'avait pas honoré
le commandement de Deutéronome 6,
verset 5,
Dieu était en train
d'apporter le jugement.
Mais quand il apportait ce jugement,
c'était après plusieurs siècles de patience.
Donc, quand nous lisons
Ézéchiel,
nous sommes à peu près
cinq siècles avant Jésus-Christ.
Et lorsque nous voyons
l'alliance qui a été établie
par Moïse et le peuple,
cette alliance a été établie
1200 ans avant Jésus-Christ.
Donc, c'était 12 siècles avant Christ.
Et là, nous sommes donc
cinq siècles avant Christ.
Donc, ça fait à peu près
sept siècles de patience
où Dieu n'a pas accompli
littéralement tout ce qu'il avait accompli.
C'est-à-dire,
Dieu, à cause de leur désobéissance,
Dieu les a punis,
mais ensuite,
Dieu les restaurait.
Mais cette fois-ci,
il y a un jugement plus grave.
Dieu promet qu'il va dévaster tout le pays
et que cette fois-ci,
ils vont vivre quelque chose
qu'il n'avait jamais vécu.
À un moment,
Dieu permettait que des nations
prennent une partie du territoire
et ensuite,
il y avait des juges,
il y avait des rois
qui libéraient l'autre partie.
Là, Dieu dit que tout le pays
sera pris,
tout le pays sera détruit.
Ça n'était jamais arrivé.
Alors, imaginez,
en sept siècles,
Israël n'avait jamais vécu ça.
Donc, ils étaient dans une forme,
une fausse assurance
de se dire
que ces choses ne peuvent pas arriver.
Certes, Dieu va punir.
Certes, même,
certains ont même attribué ça au hasard
en se disant
que ce n'est pas la main de Dieu.
Mais le passage,
quand Dieu reprend ce passage,
Ézéchiel reprend littéralement
ce que Dieu avait dit
dans l'hévétique,
dans Deutéronome,
comme nous le verrons par la suite.
Et Dieu apporte
sa signature personnelle.
Nous l'avons dit la dernière fois,
il apportait cette signature personnelle.
Vous pouvez,
là, nous avons lu le texte,
mais dans le chapitre 5,
à la fin,
il y avait beaucoup
de ces expressions,
c'est moi l'éternel qui parle.
Et là, dans le chapitre 6,
vous voyez,
ils sauront
et ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel.
Ils sauront
Plusieurs fois,
il va parler des jugements à venir
et il dit
ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel.
Dieu est en train
de préciser
que tout cela
ne sera pas
le fruit du hasard.
Certains pouvaient penser
à un moment
que ça,
c'est,
on a dit ça depuis sept siècles,
cinq,
c'est pas une considération.
Ce n'est pas Dieu,
c'est juste le fruit du hasard.
Mais Dieu est en train
d'accomplir des prophéties
annoncées plusieurs siècles avant
de façon littérale
pour que Israël comprenne
que c'est l'éternel.
Et donc,
cette fois-ci,
au début du chapitre 6,
Dieu demande à Ézéchiel
de prononcer le jugement
pas seulement sur Jérusalem,
mais sur l'ensemble
du pays d'Israël.
Et la vérité
qui est profonde,
la vérité centrale
de ce texte,
c'est de voir
comment Dieu veille
pour accomplir sa parole.
Vous imaginez
quelque chose
qui a été annoncé
sept siècles avant
et qui se reproduit
de façon littérale,
exactement.
Dieu veille
pour accomplir sa parole,
donc c'est la vérité centrale
pour nous
que nous devons comprendre ça.
Dieu veille
pour accomplir sa parole,
non seulement en annonçant
la destruction d'Israël,
mais aussi la destruction
de leurs idoles
avec eux.
Et nous allons voir
qu'est-ce que signifie
le jugement
lorsqu'il parle
du jugement
contre les montagnes
d'Israël.
Qu'est-ce qu'il est en train
de signifier aussi
par cette prophétie
lorsqu'il est en train
de parler
de la destruction
des idoles
et de ceux
qui adorent les idoles.
Le premier point,
je peux même dire
le grand 1,
ça va être ce que nous
devons comprendre
lorsqu'il est en train
de dire
« Fils de l'homme,
tourne ta face
vers les montagnes
d'Israël. »
Que signifie le jugement
contre les montagnes
d'Israël ?
Laisons,
nous l'avons lu,
versets 1 à 2,
« La parole de l'Éternel
me fut adressée
en ces mots.
Fils de l'homme,
tourne ta face
vers les montagnes
d'Israël
et prophétise contre elle. »
Dieu demande
au prophète
Ézéchiel
de tourner son visage
contre les montagnes
d'Israël.
Ézéchiel était,
à l'époque,
Ézéchiel avait été
déporté à Babylone
et Dieu lui dit
à un moment,
dans cette imagination,
de s'imaginer
voir Israël
et qui peut voir
Israël au loin ?
Il est en train
de voir les montagnes.
D'ailleurs,
si vous êtes dans le train,
quand vous êtes en train
de voyager en train,
la première chose
qui va nous frapper,
généralement,
ce n'est pas la voiture
qui est dans un coin.
Nous allons regarder
les paysages,
nous allons voir
les montagnes,
les vallées,
ce que tu peux observer
de la nature.
Et là,
Dieu est en train
de dire à Ézéchiel,
regarde,
regarde les montagnes
d'Israël.
Il demande à Ézéchiel,
sur la façon
dont il est en train
d'imposer
avec l'impératif,
il dit à Ézéchiel
de regarder
ces montagnes
avec fermeté,
de les regarder
comme un juge
qui serait en train
de regarder
un prisonnier
à qui il est en train
d'annoncer une sentence.
Par définition,
là encore,
je vais dire,
nous avons tous vu
une montagne,
n'est-ce pas ?
Si tu n'as pas vu
de montagne,
là c'est un problème.
C'est que tu es né à Paris,
tu as vécu à Paris depuis...
Mais normalement,
nous avons tous déjà vu
une montagne dans notre vie.
Une montagne est haute.
Quand nous nous plaçons
au pied d'une montagne,
la montagne est haute,
la montagne paraît forte.
Et Dieu demande à Ézéchiel
de garder cette image,
mais de s'adresser
aux montagnes.
dans le sens
où les jugements
qui sont prononcés
contre Israël,
c'est pour montrer
l'importance,
c'est-à-dire,
ces jugements seraient
à même débranler
des montagnes.
Il est en train de dire
à un moment,
même les montagnes d'Israël
vont être ébranlées
par le jugement.
Ces montagnes
avaient été autrefois saintes.
Quand le peuple d'Israël
est rentré,
quand Dieu leur a donné
ce territoire,
c'était des montagnes saintes.
Mais maintenant,
le jugement est contre
ces montagnes
parce qu'elles ont été profanées,
parce qu'Israël
avait construit des hôtels
pour des idoles
sur ces montagnes.
Parce qu'à un moment,
c'est un peu
dans la compréhension,
à un moment,
dans toutes ces religions
païennes,
à un moment,
il était important
de souvent construire
des hôtels aux dieux.
On n'allait pas les construire
en bas,
on allait les construire
au sommet d'une montagne
parce que c'était
cette représentation
de puissance et autres.
Donc, on va construire
des hôtels.
Et donc,
ils avaient construit
des hôtels
sur ces montagnes
et Dieu est en train
de dire,
à cause des souillures
que vous avez faites
en souillant ces montagnes,
Dieu va tourner
sa face contre elles
et il demande
aux prophètes
de parler ainsi.
Mais,
nous voyons encore,
là c'est un peu
ce que j'étais en train
de dire au début,
nous voyons la conséquence
et souvent,
nous sommes là
à nous questionner
mais pourquoi
ces choses arrivent ?
Aujourd'hui,
nous voyons
la création
qui n'est plus
soumise à l'homme.
nous nous plaignons
des moustiques
mais les moustiques
sont les conséquences
du péché de l'homme.
Les moustiques
n'ont rien à voir.
Bien sûr,
je ne vous demande pas
de ne pas les tuer
le soir
s'ils vous embêtent
mais que nous soyons
conscients un moment
que toutes ces choses
sont le fruit
du péché de l'homme.
Le fait que la nature
se rebelle contre nous
c'est le fruit
de notre péché
et souvent,
nous avons plutôt tendance
à dire un moment
mais pourquoi Dieu
permet cela ?
Mais Dieu permet cela
parce que nous avons
désobéi.
Mais nous savons
que quand Dieu
est en train de parler
de cette colère
contre les montagnes,
en fait,
Dieu est en train
de tourner sa colère
contre le peuple d'Israël.
Dieu décide
de désigner Israël
non par les tribus
mais il est en train
de désigner Israël
par le pays.
Et il est en train
de dire les montagnes,
donc il demande aux montagnes
d'écouter le jugement
de l'éternel.
Les montagnes sont appelées
à écouter la parole
de l'éternel
pour couvrir de honte
le peuple
qui refusait
de l'écouter.
Et il y a même
un passage encore plus clair
dans Miché,
il reprend cet exemple,
voilà ce qu'il dit
dans Miché,
écoutez donc
ce que dit l'éternel,
lève-toi,
plaide devant les montagnes
et que les collines
entendent ta voix.
Écoutez montagne,
le procès de l'éternel
et vous,
solide fondement de la terre,
car l'éternel
a un procès
avec son peuple,
il veut plaider
avec Israël.
Dieu était en train
de dire
que dans la confusion,
c'est-à-dire Israël
est arrivé à un tel point
de désobéissance
que Dieu est en train
de prendre la création
à témoin
contre Israël.
Dieu indique par là
que son jugement
sera entendu.
Quand Dieu est en train
de faire ça,
il est en train d'indiquer
que son jugement
sera entendu,
que Israël le veuille
ou non.
Et si vous vous souvenez,
le message central,
au début,
lorsque Dieu établit
le ministère d'Ézéchiel,
une des choses
qu'il lui rappelle beaucoup
et par lesquelles il l'encourage,
c'est de lui dire un moment,
tu vas exhorter ce peuple
et ce peuple ne t'écoutera pas.
Tu vas leur annoncer
ces choses graves
et ce peuple va refuser
de t'écouter.
Et lorsqu'ils vont
finalement croire
Ézéchiel,
mais on va même dire croire
d'une certaine façon,
c'est lorsque Jérusalem
va être détruite
parce que là,
Jérusalem n'est pas encore détruite.
Ézéchiel est en train
d'annoncer la destruction
de Jérusalem.
Le peuple croit
que Dieu
va encore s'associer
à leur péché
et qu'il va sauver Israël.
C'est-à-dire,
à un moment,
ils avaient décidé
de faire une alliance
avec le roi,
le pharaon d'Égypte
et ils espéraient
que ça les sauve
de l'emprise
de Nebuchadnezzar,
le roi de Babylone.
Mais Ézéchiel leur dit,
n'espérez même pas
dans le secours de l'Égypte,
vous serez détruits.
Mais Dieu avertit Ézéchiel
en lui disant,
un moment,
ils ne comprendront pas,
ils ne vont pas saisir
la colère de l'Éternel.
Même là,
lorsque je suis en train
de pointer un péché
qu'ils ont commis
depuis plusieurs siècles,
ils ne voudront pas accepter.
Et Dieu décide
de prendre
la création à témoin.
Et c'est grave
parce que si nous arrivons
à là,
ça veut dire un moment
que Dieu a décidé
que son jugement
soit accompli.
Une des choses
qui nous parle là-dessus,
souvenons-nous
de l'entrée
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
à Jérusalem,
juste avant sa mort,
la semaine de sa mort.
Quand il rentre
à Jérusalem
et que les enfants
sont en train de crier,
les enfants sont en train
de crier,
béni soit le roi
qui vient au nom du Seigneur.
Il y a quelques pharisiens
qui vont lui dire un moment,
mais reprends tes disciples,
ils lui demandent
de se taire.
Et le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
leur dit un moment,
s'ils se taisent,
les pierres crieront.
Si Dieu arrive au point
où à un moment,
il est en train de parler
de cette symbolique
que parce que
le peuple
n'est pas en train
d'honorer le Seigneur,
le peuple n'est pas en train
de proclamer
qui est l'Éternel,
alors la création
va servir de témoin
contre le peuple.
Mais là,
Dieu est en train de dire,
là,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
était en train de dire,
vous avez encore de l'espérance,
vous avez encore la possibilité
de vous repentir
parce qu'ils sont en train
de chanter,
ils sont en train de proclamer,
de reconnaître
que je suis l'Éternel.
Mais s'ils se taisent,
les pierres crieront.
Et là,
Dieu est arrivé à un point
où il est en train
de dire à la création,
il est en train de dire
colline,
montagne d'Israël
écoutez ce que j'ai à dire
contre le peuple d'Israël.
Ça,
ça voulait dire
que le jugement
était arrêté.
Ce qu'il était en train
de dire à Ézéchiel,
c'est qu'Ézéchiel
devait faire comprendre
au peuple
que lorsque Dieu
est en train
de s'adresser à la création
pour la prendre
comme témoin,
c'est que sa décision
est arrêtée.
Et c'était pour les appeler
à la repentance.
Et ce point doit nous rappeler,
c'est très important,
et nous sommes bénis
en ce moment
par l'étude
que nous sommes en train
de faire
par rapport à la crainte
de l'homme,
comment nous devons
comprendre la crainte
de l'homme,
mais aussi la crainte
de Dieu.
Ce point aussi nous rappelle
de ne pas avoir honte
de l'Évangile.
Ce point nous rappelle aussi
que si nous avons
honte de l'Évangile,
Dieu se chargera
de sauver.
Mais Dieu nous a fait
dans son amour gracieux,
Dieu a choisi
de travailler avec nous
pour que l'Évangile
soit annoncé aux nations.
Mais si à un moment
nous décidons,
nous considérons
à un moment
que nous avons
honte de l'Évangile
ou que nous ne voyons
pas le besoin
d'annoncer l'Évangile,
alors sachons-le,
la création sera prise
à témoin
de ce que nous sommes
en train de faire.
Le jugement viendra,
mais le jugement viendra
et le peuple de Dieu
qui n'a pas annoncé
la parole de Dieu
sera aussi jugé.
Si le peuple de Dieu
n'a pas annoncé
la parole de Dieu
aussi comme il le devait,
il sera jugé.
Paul va dire
« Je t'en conjure »
il parle à Timothée,
2 Timothée 4,
versets 1 à 5
« Je t'en conjure
devant Dieu
et devant Jésus-Christ
qui doit juger
les vivants et les morts
et au nom de son apparition
et de son royaume. »
Vous voyez,
là c'est la même chose.
À un moment,
Israël devait être
la lumière des nations.
C'est-à-dire,
Israël devait,
en reflétant
les lois de l'Éternel,
Israël devait montrer
aux nations
que Dieu était l'Éternel
et qu'une nation
qui a été préservée
pendant plusieurs siècles
en portant ce message,
c'est la nation
qui devait montrer aux nations
que Dieu devait libérer
les nations
du pouvoir du péché,
de l'emprise de Satan.
Et c'était le rôle d'Israël.
Israël a échoué.
Et là,
vous voyez,
Paul dit à un moment,
« Je t'en conjure »
devant Dieu
et devant Jésus-Christ
qui doit juger
les vivants et les morts.
Ce n'est pas que nous ayons
le choix de dire un moment,
tu peux aujourd'hui dire
« Je ne crois pas en ça,
je ne crois pas que Dieu
jugera les vivants et les morts. »
À la même époque,
au temps d'Ézéchiel,
certains disaient
« Je ne crois pas
au jugement de Dieu. »
Mais Ézéchiel est en train
de dire
« Que vous le vouliez ou non,
Dieu jugera Israël. »
Et là,
c'est la même chose.
« Que nous le voulions ou non,
annonçons l'Évangile
car Dieu jugera
les vivants et les morts. »
Même si aujourd'hui,
il y a des vivants
qui ne croient pas
au jugement de l'Éternel,
Dieu jugera
les vivants et les morts.
Et à partir de ça,
qu'est-ce que Paul dit
à Timothée ?
Prêche la parole.
Insiste en toute occasion.
Favorable ou non.
Bien sûr,
c'est avec sagesse.
Reprend,
censure,
exhorte
avec toute douceur
et en instruisant.
Car il viendra un temps,
et vous voyez,
c'est un temps qui est parallèle.
Ce que Paul est en train de dire,
c'est ce même temps
que nous nous retrouvons
à l'époque
avec Ézéchiel.
C'est ce même temps
que nous pouvons retrouver pour nous.
« Car il viendra un temps
où les hommes ne supporteront
pas la saine doctrine,
mais ayant la démangeaison
d'entendre des choses agréables,
ils se donneront
une foule de docteurs
selon leurs propres désirs. »
C'est ce que Israël avait fait.
Israël avait décidé
de ne plus écouter
la loi de l'Éternel.
Ils avaient décidé
de la mélanger
avec la loi
des autres,
des dieux païens.
Ils avaient mis
toute cette confusion.
Et là,
Paul le rappelle ça aussi
pour cette génération.
« Ils se donneront
une foule de docteurs
selon leurs propres désirs,
détourneront l'oreille
de la vérité
et se tourneront
vers les fables.
Mais toi,
sois sobre en toutes choses,
supporte les souffrances,
fais l'œuvre
d'un évangéliste,
remplis bien ton ministère. »
Annonçons l'Évangile.
Dieu nous fait grâce
d'être ces messagers.
N'ayons pas honte
de témoigner.
Sinon,
Dieu trouvera des voies
pour le faire,
mais sans nous.
Et on ne va pas lire
le passage,
mais rappelons-nous
de cet avertissement
qui a été fait à Esther.
À un moment,
Mardoché lui dit
« Si tu n'interviens pas,
sache que le secours
viendra de l'Éternel.
Mais si tu ne le fais pas,
sache que toi,
même lorsque tu espères
pouvoir être préservé,
tu risques d'avoir
ce jugement. »
Le deuxième point,
donc ce premier point,
c'était,
le premier point,
c'était les versets 1
de ce grand 1,
c'était les versets 1 et 2.
Le deuxième point
se trouve dans le verset 3.
Il dit
« Tu diras montagne éternelle,
montagne d'Israël,
écoutez la parole
du Seigneur de l'Éternel.
Ainsi parle le Seigneur.
L'Éternel,
aux montagnes
et aux collines,
aux ravins
et aux vallées,
voici,
je fais venir
l'épée contre vous
et je détruirai
vos lieux. »
Dieu est en train
de dire
« Des montagnes,
la parole du jugement
va se répandre
jusqu'aux collines,
jusqu'aux fleuves,
jusqu'aux vallées. »
Ce que Dieu est juste
en train
de nous signaler
au travers de ça,
c'est que tout le pays
sera témoin
du jugement de Dieu.
Là, c'était important
parce que Dieu
était en train de parler.
Il n'y aura pas juste
Jérusalem
qui va être prise,
c'est l'ensemble du pays
qui va être pris.
Et là encore,
comme je vous ai dit,
c'était quelque chose
qui n'était jamais arrivé
en plus de sept siècles.
L'ensemble du pays
n'avait jamais été pris.
Dieu est en train
de parler d'un jugement
qu'Israël ne connaît pas.
Et Dieu dit
à un moment
qu'il fera venir
ce jugement
contre ces hauts lieux
parce que Dieu
les a avertis
pendant plusieurs siècles.
Dieu a envoyé
ces prophètes.
D'ailleurs,
rappelons-nous-mêmes,
il y a même un prophète,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
parle de Zacharie
qui a été tué
entre le temple
et l'autel
pour parler
de ce symbole
de tous ces hommes.
Ces prophètes
qui pendant plusieurs siècles
ont mis en garde
le peuple
contre ce qui devait arriver
et le peuple
a choisi
de ne pas obéir
pendant plusieurs siècles,
pendant sept siècles.
Nous n'arrivons pas
à me gêner la portée.
Souvent,
nous allons nous dire
mais pourquoi Dieu,
quand nous voyons
les jugements de Dieu,
nous réfléchissons
toujours à court terme.
Quand le jugement
de Dieu se manifeste,
nous trouvons
qu'il a manqué
de patience,
d'amour.
Mais quand les jugements
de Dieu se manifestent,
c'est qu'il a manifesté
tellement de patience,
tellement d'amour
et qu'à un moment,
il ne peut plus
tolérer le péché
au point où le péché
est arrivé,
au point où la pratique
du péché est arrivée
et le jugement de Dieu
arrive sur les nations.
Le grand 2
que nous pouvons voir
dans le grand 2,
que signifie cette prophétie
de destruction des idoles
et de ceux
qui adorent les idoles ?
Le premier point,
nous le trouvons
dans les versets 4 à 6
que je vais relire.
4 à 6.
Une chose,
dit comme ça,
ça peut être difficile,
mais ce que nous devons voir
au travers de ce livre,
c'est un livre
qui est difficile,
mais mon exhortation
chaque fois,
c'est de voir
que c'est un livre
qui parle de l'amour de Dieu.
C'est un livre
qui parle de l'amour.
Il peut être difficile
si nous réfléchissons
à court terme,
si nous nous arrêtons
à l'instant présent
et que nous n'arrivons pas
à voir ce qui se passe avant
et ce qui se passe après.
comme je vous ai dit,
les hauts lieux,
Israël avait construit
des hauts lieux
pour adorer les idoles.
Ils avaient,
et le fait qu'ils avaient
violé ce premier commandement,
tu aimeras l'éternel,
ton Dieu,
de tout ton cœur,
de toute ton âme,
de toute ta force,
les avait conduits
à ouvrir la porte
à d'autres péchés
encore plus graves.
Et même ces péchés
de négligence,
parce que le péché
de ne pas respecter le sabbat,
le péché
de mépriser le pauvre,
la veuve,
l'orphelin,
ce sont ces péchés
qui sont dénoncés
plusieurs fois
par les prophètes.
Si vous lisez,
comme je vous lisez,
l'ensemble des prophètes
et notamment même
les petits prophètes,
comme on dit entre guillemets,
beaucoup vont parler
de cette injustice sociale
et c'est cette injustice
qui a apporté le jugement.
Et donc,
ils avaient fait des hauts lieux
sous les sommets des montagnes
et Dieu est en train de dire
que ces hauts lieux
seront détruits,
ces hauts lieux seront rasés
et ne pourront plus
s'en servir
comme c'était le cas
avant le jugement.
Parce que ce qui se passe,
c'est qu'à un moment,
quand Dieu permettait
à des juges
ou à des rois fidèles
à l'éternel,
à un moment,
il arrivait que ces juges,
ces rois détruisent
ces hauts lieux.
Mais ce qui se passait
à leur mort,
c'est que ces hauts lieux
étaient reconstruits.
Il suffisait qu'un roi,
un pays arrive
ou que le peuple,
après un juge
qui avait honoré l'éternel,
décide de repartir
dans le péché
et reconstruisait
ces hauts lieux.
Mais maintenant,
Dieu est en train de dire
que ces hauts lieux
seront totalement détruits,
seront totalement rasés.
Ces hôtels
sur lesquels
le peuple offrait
des sacrifices
et brûlait de l'encens
à d'autres dieux
seront totalement brisés,
seront totalement dévastés.
Les idoles
qui s'étaient construites,
c'étaient des idoles
de pierre,
des idoles
avec des éléments
de la création.
toutes ces idoles
seraient profanées,
elles seraient détruites,
abattues,
malgré tous les efforts
qu'ils avaient faits
pour les façonner.
Quelques points là-dessus,
il précise donc
que la guerre
qui va arriver
va produire
de terribles désolations
et même ces choses,
même ces lieux
et ces choses
qui étaient considérées
comme les plus sacrées
ne pourraient pas échapper.
Et l'ironie
de la situation,
c'est que
Dieu
permet la destruction
d'Israël
qui était
devenu un pays idolâtre
et permet la destruction
par une nation
qui elle-même
était encore
plus idolâtre.
C'est ça
qui était le comte,
c'est-à-dire
que les babyloniens
étaient encore même
plus idolâtres
que le peuple d'Israël.
Mais ce que Dieu
pointe à Israël,
c'est qu'avec la connaissance
de la parole de Dieu,
leur jugement
était même encore pire
que le jugement
des babyloniens
qui allaient venir
parce qu'ils connaissaient
ce qu'ils devaient faire.
Ils savaient
ce qui était juste.
qu'ils ne devaient pas
avoir d'idole
au milieu
de leur territoire.
À cause de ça,
le jugement
était terrible
et ce jugement
était même apporté
par une nation idolâtre.
Chacune de ces nations
à l'époque
avait son Dieu
qu'ils adoraient localement
et pour Babylone
par exemple,
lorsque vous aviez
ces nations aussi,
une nation écrasait
une autre,
c'était la défaite
du Dieu
qui protégeait
cette nation.
Ça veut dire
que ce Dieu
était incapable
de veiller
sur cette nation.
C'est important
et voilà pourquoi
c'est là où
nous devons nous souvenir
pourquoi Dieu
est en train
d'apporter
ce que j'appelais
sa signature personnelle.
Pourquoi Dieu précise
un moment en disant
c'est moi l'éternel
qui parle.
Pourquoi il précise
que lorsque
ces jugements vont arriver,
ils vont savoir
qu'il est l'éternel.
Pourquoi il précise
même un moment
que certains d'entre vous
vont s'échapper
et pourront témoigner
de ce qu'ils ont vécu.
Parce que Dieu
est en train de dire
même lorsque
Babylone
va dire un moment
que ce sont
nos dieux
qui ont écrasé
vos dieux,
sachez-le
que même
Babylone
a été utilisée
par moi
pour apporter
le jugement.
Voilà pourquoi
Dieu est en train
de parler
Dieu se dissocie
des dieux des nations
et du péché d'Israël
par ce jugement
prononcé à l'avance.
Dieu se dissocie
et ne pouvait pas
avoir de trouble.
Peut-être pour les Babyloniens
ils pourraient avoir
du trouble
parce que pour les Babyloniens
ils étaient sûrs
que ce sont leurs dieux
qui leur avaient donné
cette terre d'Israël.
Mais Dieu est en train
de dire
quand les Babyloniens
vous frapperont
que ces hôtels
seront dévastés
que tout sera détruit
vous allez vous souvenir
que je vous avais
annoncé cela
plusieurs siècles avant.
Et comme je vous disais
ceux qui ont compris cela
des hommes
comme Ézéchiel et Daniel
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ?
C'est qu'ils ont décidé
d'intercéder
pour demander pardon à Dieu.
Ils n'ont pas dit
un moment
mais Seigneur
qu'est-ce que tu es
en train de faire ?
Seigneur comment
ce peuple que tu as dit
à un moment
que nous serons
la prunelle de tes yeux
comment tu décides ?
Non.
Daniel
commence sa prière
d'intercession
en disant
nous avons péché
nos pères ont péché
pendant plusieurs générations
nous avons ignoré
jusqu'à ce que cela nous arrive.
Et c'est important
parce que Dieu
était en train de dire
un moment
vous allez comprendre
que ces idoles sont vaines.
Ces idoles
bien sûr
quand Babylone va détruire
Babylone va écraser
les idoles
Babylone va tuer
ils vont verser le sang
des gens qu'ils ont tués
sur ces idoles
en disant
ces idoles n'ont pas su
vous protéger
mais Dieu se dissocie
Dieu dit
ils sauront que je suis
l'éternel.
même Babylone
si vous vous souvenez
lorsque Jérémie
Jérémie a eu la grâce
d'être le seul
lorsque les Babyloniens
vont prendre
Jérusalem
la seule personne
qui est autorisée
à aller où elle veut
c'est Jérémie.
Ils vont lui dire
un moment
parce que nous avons entendu
tout ce que tu as annoncé
à ce peuple depuis
que tu avais même annoncé
que nous allions prendre
Jérusalem
tu es libre
d'aller où tu veux.
Et quand ils disent
que tu es libre
d'aller où tu veux
ils ont entendu
les prophéties de Jérémie
que Jérémie
est en train de dire
Babylone arrive
parce que vous avez péché
mais c'est bien
bien sûr
dans l'esprit de Babylone
ils étaient sûrs
que ce sont leurs dieux
qui leur donnaient
mais derrière
c'était Dieu
qui avait orchestré cela.
Donc Dieu
s'est dissocié
des idoles
qui étaient en train
d'être frappées
dans Israël
et lorsqu'ils rappellent
un moment
ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel
ils rappellent
un moment
que même si Babylone
était guidée
par ses propres intérêts
c'est la main de Dieu
qui était derrière.
Et une leçon pour nous
et même pour Israël
ça a été la leçon
et pour nous aussi
c'est un avertissement fort.
Il sera juste
que Dieu fasse des idoles
que nous pouvons avoir
dans nos vies
des désolations.
Vous voyez ce qui va se passer
les babyloniens
vont détruire ces idoles
ces idoles dans lesquelles
Israël espérait
depuis des siècles
en rejetant l'éternel
ils étaient sûrs
que ces idoles
allaient les protéger
jusqu'au bout
mais ces idoles
ont été incapables
de les protéger.
Aujourd'hui
encore
nous aussi
il va nous arriver
un moment
de nous constituer
des idoles
lorsque nous allons
placer des choses
que nous considérons
comme étant
plus importantes que Dieu
à un moment
je vais placer
mon emploi
plus important que Dieu
et si je perds mon emploi
ma vie n'a plus de sens
ça c'est déjà
une idole
si à un moment
je considère
un moment
qu'une chose
qui est dans ma vie
si je la perd
ma vie n'a plus de sens
si ce n'est Dieu
c'est que cette chose
est une idole pour moi
et nous devons faire attention
parce que
pour notre Dieu
comme Dieu est en train
de punir Israël
et ce que Dieu
est en train de faire
nous l'avons aussi vu
il y a deux semaines
à la fin
Dieu est en train
de purifier Israël
ce jugement
il est en train
de purifier
la nation d'Israël
afin que
devienne
ce refuge
cet accueil
pour le Messie
ils n'étaient pas prêts
ils étaient en train
de prendre un mauvais chemin
et ce que Dieu va faire
c'est que
il va
les frapper
par ce jugement
au bout de 70 ans
il va les ramener
et là encore
il avait promis cela
pendant plusieurs
siècles avance
il va les ramener
et quand il les ramène
c'est là où nous avons
les dernières prophéties
nous avons les derniers
Malachie, Zacharie
nous avons les derniers prophètes
et après nous avons
un silence de 4 siècles
nous avons un silence
de 4 siècles
au cours duquel
au bout de ces 4 siècles
nous avons un ange
qui apparaît
à Marie
un ange
Gabriel qui apparaît
à Elisabeth
à Marie
et c'est le début
de l'oeuvre rédemptrice
mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce que nous comprenons
par là
c'est qu'après
cette purification
Dieu
la nation
la voie que la nation
a choisie après
c'était la voie
qu'il fallait
pour pouvoir préparer
la venue du Messie
donc il est juste
un moment
que si Dieu constate
des idoles
dans nos vies
que Dieu va faire
de ces idoles
des désolations
et voilà pourquoi
les hommes
qui se confient
dans ce qu'ils vont
créer comme idole
dans leur vie
ne vont jamais trouver
la paix
la paix seule
ne peut être trouvée
que lorsque nous
la plaçons en Dieu
si nous créons
une idole
de notre vie
par rapport
nos enfants
peuvent être une idole
notre travail
peut être une idole
même les frères et sœurs
de l'église
peuvent être des idoles
lorsque les frères et sœurs
de l'église
vont être une idole
si je suis déçu
par les frères et sœurs
de l'église
le témoignage de Christ
je suis même déçu
de l'évangile
je suis déçu
des chrétiens
de l'église
parce que j'ai été déçu
par des frères
si c'est le cas
c'est que j'avais fait
des frères une idole
notre seule espérance
doit être en Christ
et nous n'avons pas
été créés
chaque fois que nous
sommes en train
de faire ça
nous sommes en train
d'aller dans le mauvais sens
nous n'avons pas été créés
pour adorer les créatures
mais nous avons été
créés pour adorer
le créateur
l'idolâtrie
et c'était le problème
d'Israël
l'idolâtrie
c'est changer
la vérité de Dieu
en mensonge
l'idolâtrie
c'est le fait
d'adorer
et de servir
la créature
au lieu du créateur
c'était le problème
d'Israël
Israël
avait eu ce penchant
dans le cœur
ils avaient refusé
d'aimer l'éternel
de tout leur cœur
leur âme
et leur force
à partir de là
dans leur cœur
il y avait eu
une déviance
et ils se sont construits
des idoles
et le jugement
a arrivé
nous devons nous souvenir
que notre Dieu
est un Dieu jaloux
nous devons nous souvenir
que notre Dieu
est un Dieu
qui ne supporte pas
de rival
car il n'y a rien
qui puisse être comparé
à lui
il y a souvent
nous avons souvent
dans les milieux chrétiens
nous avons des allusions
on va dire un moment
que Dieu
Dieu est à la première place
de mon cœur
Dieu doit être
à la première place
de notre cœur
mais le problème
c'est que Dieu
n'est même pas
dans une catégorie
Dieu est en dehors
de ces catégories
Dieu ne peut pas être comparé
où nous allons le placer
à la première
et la deuxième
et la troisième
et à un moment
si on décide
à un moment
il passe à la deuxième
parce qu'on a
non
Dieu est hors
de ces catégories
nous devons le comprendre
notre Dieu
n'a pas de rival
n'a aucune catégorie
de comparaison
qui peut lui être
appliquée
et si à un moment
nous ne travaillons pas
à préserver
nos cœurs
de l'idolâtrie
et si à un moment
nous nous laissons
aller à des cœurs
idolâtres
Dieu se chargera
de détruire
l'idolâtrie
Dieu a créé
les nations
pour que les nations
puissent l'adorer
et à cause de la chute
nous décidons
à un moment
d'adorer
nous décidons
d'adorer autre chose
aujourd'hui
les nations
nous sommes
dans l'adoration
de la puissance
du profit
de beaucoup d'autres choses
les nations
ont constitué
leurs idoles
et vous allez même
aller d'une nation
à une autre
il y a des idoles
qu'on retrouve
qui sont semblables
mais selon les profils
de certaines nations
vous allez trouver
des caractéristiques
de péché
plus approfondies
selon elles
selon leur culture
mais le problème
c'est que ce n'est pas
cela que Dieu
les avait appelés
et à un moment
quand nous laissons
l'idolâtrie
et que nous
n'appliquons pas
Deutéronome 6
il est inéluctable
que le jugement
de Dieu
arrivera
de façon inéluctable
et si nous sommes
croyants
et qu'à un moment
nous sommes en train
de lutter
pour ne pas laisser
Dieu
être dans notre vie
Dieu se chargera
aussi de détruire
l'idolâtrie
de notre coeur
c'est quelque chose
dont nous devons
être conscients
un moment que
vous voyez
l'exemple qui est pris
plusieurs fois
dans l'histoire
d'Israël
Dieu a levé
des hommes
c'était des juges
c'était des prophètes
c'était des rois
et pendant un temps
ils ont détruit
ces hauts lieux
les idoles
et on se souvient
notamment du roi
Josias
Josias c'est même
celui qui est allé
le plus loin
où dans tout le pays
il a détruit
les idoles
parce qu'avant
les rois le faisaient
mais ils ne le faisaient
pas de façon totale
mais Josias
l'a fait
de façon totale
sur tout le pays
il s'est assuré
un moment
qu'il n'y ait plus
un hôtel
qui subsiste
mais pourtant
après sa mort
tous ces hôtels
ont été reconstruits
mais cette fois-ci
Dieu promet
un moment
qui va détruire
ces hôtels
avec fermeté
travaillant
comme je dis
notre Dieu
est un Dieu jaloux
et le péché
le péché produit
l'idolâtrie
dans le cœur
veillant sur nos cœurs
il n'y a pas
il n'y a aucune catégorie
dans laquelle
nous pouvons placer Dieu
pour essayer
de le comparer
à certaines choses
mais nous devons
chaque fois faire attention
nous devons examiner
nos vies
pour être sûr
à un moment
que nous ne sommes pas
en train d'élever
quelque chose
que nous considérons
plus important que Dieu
bien sûr à un moment
il est nécessaire
que nous apportions
des soins à notre famille
mais nous devons faire attention
à ce que notre épouse
nos enfants
notre mari
ne soit pas
une idole
que les choses
ici bas
toutes choses ici bas
sous les cieux
ne soient pas une idole
même des choses
de la création
le deuxième point
nous avons donc vu
le premier point
c'était
ce que nous avons vu
des versets 4 à 6
les idoles
et tout ce qui va
avec leur culte
qui seront détruits
le deuxième point
c'est
les adorateurs
de ces idoles
qui seront détruits
de la même manière
et là nous lisons
les versets 5 à 7
je mettrai les cadavres
des enfants d'Israël
devant leurs idoles
et je disperserai
vos ossements
autour de vos hôtels
partout où vous habitez
vos villes seront ruinées
et vos hauts lieux
dévastés
vos hôtels seront délaissés
et abandonnés
vos idoles seront brisées
et disparaîtront
vos statues du soleil
seront abattues
et vos ouvrages anéantis
les morts tomberont
au milieu de vous
et vous saurez
que je suis l'éternel
Dieu dit
que non seulement
tous les hauts lieux
seront dévastés
et entièrement détruits
mais en plus
leurs demeures
leurs villes
seront aussi dévastées
et comme je vous ai dit
c'était du jamais vu
dans toute l'histoire
mais là encore
Dieu était clair là-dessus
et il souligne
pourquoi ce jugement
est arrivé
nous l'avons médité
lorsque nous avions
parcouru le chapitre 5
au verset 11
il va dire
c'est pourquoi je suis vivant
dit le Seigneur l'éternel
parce que tu as souillé
mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles
et toutes tes abominations
moi aussi je retirerai mon oeil
et mon oeil sera sans pitié
moi aussi je n'aurai point
de miséricorde
si quelqu'un détruit
le temple de Dieu
Dieu le détruira
si nous sommes
dans la négligence
de ce que Dieu
nous a donné
Dieu
détruira
ce que nous plaçons
comme assurance
il est précisé
au verset 7
que les morts
tomberont au milieu d'eux
ce que Dieu
est en train de dire
c'est que même là
vous allez penser
être en sécurité
c'est même
dans le verset 4
et je ferai tomber
vos morts
devant vos idoles
même là où ils pensaient
pouvoir être en sécurité
Dieu allait les rattraper
certains allaient tomber
devant les idoles
imaginez
ce sur quoi
ils plaçaient leur assurance
ils avaient placé
leur assurance
et ces choses
étaient en train
de les décevoir
et leurs cadavres
leurs eaux
allaient être dispersés
autour de leurs hôtels
alors ce qui est bon
à préciser
c'est que là
nous ne sommes pas
en train de parler
de quelque chose
d'allégorique
c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé
plus tard
dans le jugement
quand les Babyloniens
sont arrivés
ils voulaient représenter
par rapport à la puissance
que leur Dieu
leur avait donnée
la victoire
que leur Dieu
leur avait donnée
ils ont détruit
ils ont dévasté
les hauts lieux
ils ont tout détruit
parce que c'était la preuve
qu'ils avaient réduit
les dieux de ces nations
et que ces dieux de ces nations
étaient faibles
les vérités
il y a trois vérités
qui ressortent
de ce point
que nous voyons
par rapport au jugement
de ces autorateurs
d'idoles
qui seront détruits
de la même manière
que leurs idoles
les idoles
allaient être profanées
par les cadavres
de ceux
qu'ils vénéraient
Dieu était en train
non seulement
de montrer
la vacuité
de la foi
des Israélites
envers leurs idoles
mais il était en train
de prouver aussi
aux Israélites
que ces idoles
ne pouvaient rien faire
et souvendons-nous même
du jugement
lorsque le jugement
tombe sur l'Egypte
quand Dieu délivre
le peuple d'Israël
d'Egypte
qu'est-ce qui est rappelé ?
c'était un jugement
contre les dieux
de l'Egypte
ce que Dieu était
en train de dire
par rapport à ces Égyptiens
qui étaient dans
une idolâtrie
totale
c'est-à-dire
quand vous regardez
les dix plaies
chacune des plaies
correspond
à une idole
à chacune des plaies
c'était une idole
qui était adorée
dans le peuple d'Egypte
donc ils adoraient
même les grenouilles
si vous voyez
il y a eu
une invasion de grenouilles
c'est qu'ils avaient
une idole
qui était en forme
de grenouilles
qu'ils adoraient
ils adoraient le fleuve
et vous voyez
que tous les jugements
les dix plaies
sont dix plaies
qui vont frapper
les idoles
dans lesquelles
les Égyptiens
s'appuyaient
Dieu
est en train
de souligner
par là
que lorsque
le sang
de ceux
qui adoraient
ces idoles
allaient souiller
Dieu est en train
de souligner
par là
la vanité
de ces idoles
il est en train
de dire à Israël
Israël
ces idoles
sont vaines
alors
l'ironie
de la chose
c'est que
après cela
Israël a été délivré
du fait d'adorer
des idoles
mais ils se sont créés
d'autres formes
d'idoles
ça a été beaucoup plus
par le fait
de la justice
personnelle
par le fait
de croire
un moment
que le salut
pouvait l'acquérir
par leur sacrifice
mais là encore
c'était une autre histoire
mais ils ont été délivrés
de comprendre
ils n'ont plus placé
leur espérance
dans ces idoles
et même lorsque
après l'empire
babylonien
quelques siècles plus tard
il y a eu
les romains
les empires
nés
de l'invasion
d'Alexandre le Grand
tous ces empires
ont voulu les obliger
à adorer
d'autres dieux
d'autres idoles
ils ont refusé
ils ont été persécutés
ils ont été tués
mais ils ont refusé
d'adorer ces idoles
donc on voit
comment Dieu
a produit
au travers même
de comment Dieu
en pointant à Israël
la vanité de ces idoles
les a même délivrés
de cela
il leur a permis
de comprendre
cette fois-ci
voilà le jugement
qui arrive
et ces idoles
ont été incapables
de vous sauver
non seulement
elles ont été incapables
mais elles ont été détruites
donc Dieu soulignait
à un moment
que ces idoles
qui n'avaient pas su
les protéger
étaient des choses
qui étaient mortes
et sans vie
c'était à l'image
même des cadavres
c'était des idoles
qui ne pouvaient pas entendre
des idoles
qui ne pouvaient pas parler
qui ne pouvaient pas voir
à l'image des cadavres
qui reposaient maintenant
sur ces idoles
le péché d'idolâtrie
d'Israël
était en train
d'être clairement exposé
de sorte que personne
ne pourrait douter
que ce jugement
tombe sur eux
par hasard
ils allaient être tués
parce qu'ils avaient
adoré des idoles
et non le vrai Dieu
et lisons
lisons
quelques temps avant
donc juste avant
qu'Ézéchiel
ne prononce
que Dieu parle
au travers d'Ézéchiel
voici ces passages
Lévitique 26
verset 27 à 33
voilà ce que Dieu dit
et qu'il a accompli
de façon littérale
malgré cela
si vous ne m'écoutez point
et si vous me résistez
je vous résisterai
aussi avec fureur
et je vous châtierai
cette fois plus
pour vos péchés
donc ce que Dieu
est même en train
d'indiquer là
c'est que Dieu
avait encore
la possibilité
de pardonner à Israël
c'est à dire
si Israël
la miséricorde
de Dieu est grande
si Israël
était en train
de réaliser
que tout ce qui était
en train de leur arriver
arrivait à cause
du fait qu'ils avaient
péché par ce péché
de la batterie
Dieu était encore capable
d'exercer sa miséricorde
il était encore capable
de pardonner
de ne pas détruire le pays
mais là
il dit à un moment
malgré cela
si vous ne m'écoutez
et si vous me résistez
je vous résisterai
aussi avec fureur
donc là maintenant
le jugement a arrêté
et je vous châtierai
cette fois plus
pour vos péchés
vous mangerez la chair
de vos fils
et vous mangerez
la chair de vos filles
je détruirai vos hauts lieux
j'abattrai vos statues
consacrées au soleil
je mettrai vos cadavres
sur les cadavres
de vos idoles
et mon âme
vous aura en horreur
Ézéchiel est en train
de pratiquement reprendre
c'est-à-dire Dieu
est en train de parler
à Ézéchiel
et il reprend exactement
ce qu'il avait dit
sept siècles avant
je réduirai vos villes
en désert
je ravagerai vos sanctuaires
et je ne respirerai plus
l'odeur agréable
de vos parfums
je dévasterai le pays
et vos ennemis
qui l'habiteront
en seront stupéfaits
je vous disperserai
parmi les nations
et je tirerai l'épée
après vous
votre pays sera dévasté
et vos villes
seront désertes
sept siècles avant
souvent
c'est ça un rappel
parce que souvent
aujourd'hui
dans notre culture
populaire encore chrétienne
quand on parle de prophète
c'est toujours celui
qui a une révélation spéciale
une révélation
qui sort du commun
et qu'il a à nous donner
mais
quand nous lisons bien la Bible
les prophètes ont annoncé
des choses
qui se sont passées avant
la première mission
des prophètes
c'était de rappeler
ce que disait
la loi de l'éternel
si vous examinez bien
l'entièreté des prophètes
dans l'Ancien Testament
ils étaient en train
de rappeler à Israël
ce que la loi disait
ils n'étaient pas en train
et bien sûr
à un moment
ils ont révélé des choses
à l'avance
pourquoi ?
afin qu'Israël
sache que c'est l'éternel
voilà pourquoi
Dieu permettait à Esaïe
d'annoncer des choses
qui se sont passées
des siècles après
voilà pourquoi
Dieu permettait à Jérémie
d'annoncer ces choses
qui se sont passées
des années plus tard
parce qu'il fallait
que le peuple sache
qu'il est l'éternel
mais le premier rôle
des prophètes
était vraiment
de rappeler à un moment
la loi de l'éternel
et aujourd'hui même
je dirais même
aujourd'hui
que même avec
les prophètes
les spectaculaires
qu'on a aujourd'hui
entre guillemets
aujourd'hui
on est en sensation
toujours en mal de sensation
il faut quelqu'un
qui nous annonce
une parole spéciale
et si on te rappelle
juste ce que dit
la Bible
on est déçu
parce que ce n'est pas original
on aurait voulu
quelque chose
qui sorte de l'entendement
un moment à dire
je ne sais pas
comment servir le Seigneur
on attend une révélation
mais si on te dit
bouge déjà les tables
ça ne te plaît pas
il fallait une révélation spéciale
que tu vas imposer
les mains aux malades
ou des choses comme ça
il faut quelque chose
qui sorte de l'ordinaire
non
rappelons nous un moment
bon bien sûr
là quand je suis en train de dire
je risque d'avoir
des questions derrière
nous pouvons prier
nous devons avoir
la foi de prier
pour les malades
donc je ne rentre pas
sur le détail
ce que je voulais juste dire
par là
c'est le fait
que certaines personnes
vont toujours chercher
des choses extraordinaires
des révélations extraordinaires
alors qu'à un moment
ils doivent juste
se référer à ce que dit
la parole
et elle est suffisante
et donc nous voyons
Lévitique 26
27 à 33
où Dieu annonce
ces choses
7 siècles avant
et il les renouvelle
encore à Ézéchiel
5 siècles
au 5ème siècle
Jérémie
nous parle même encore
là Jérémie
est en train d'annoncer
et les Babyloniens
ont pratiquement
fait la même chose
voilà ce que Jérémie
est en train de dire
Dieu parle à Jérémie
en ce temps là
Jérémie 8 verset 1 à 2
dit l'éternel
et là aussi
je vous fais lire
ces passages
pour que vous sachiez
que c'est l'éternel
je vous fais lire
ces passages
pour comprendre aussi
comment
c'est étonnant
de voir
et cela prouve aussi
comment Dieu
aucune idole
aucun Dieu
d'une nation
n'a pu annoncer
des choses
des siècles avant
lisez l'histoire
aucun de ces dieux
n'a pu le faire
il n'y a que l'éternel
il n'y a alors
que l'éternel
le Dieu d'Israël
qui était capable
de le faire
Jérémie 8 verset 1 à 2
en ce temps là
dit l'éternel
on tirera de leur sépulcre
les eaux des rois de Juda
les eaux de ses chefs
les eaux des sacrificateurs
les eaux des prophètes
et les eaux des habitants
de Jérusalem
on les étendra
devant le soleil
devant la lune
et devant toute l'armée
des cieux
qu'ils ont aimé
qu'ils ont servi
qu'ils ont suivi
qu'ils ont recherché
et devant lesquels
ils se sont prosternés
ça nous ramène
à ce passage
que nous avons lu
au verset 1
l'éternel qui parle
fils de l'homme
tourne ta face
vers les montagnes d'Israël
Dieu prend la création
à témoin
ils ont adoré
la créature
mais Dieu est en train
de pointer
ce n'était pas là
vous avez été dans la mauvaise adoration
au contraire
vos cadavres
seront exposés
devant le soleil
la lune
toute l'armée des cieux
et vous seront
d'aucun secours
on ne les recueillera point
on ne les enterrera point
ils seront comme du fumier
sur la terre
la mort sera préférable
à la vie
pour tous ceux
qui resteront
de cette race méchante
dans tous les lieux
où je les aurai chassés
dit l'éternel des armées
pour nous
ce passage est clair
et en conclusion
aujourd'hui
comme je vous disais
c'est l'introduction
de ce chapitre 6
quelles sont les leçons
que nous pouvons tirer
du jugement de Dieu
contre
le jugement
qui est annoncé
contre les idoles d'Israël
et contre leurs adorateurs
la conclusion
nous la trouvons
dans
le Nouveau Testament
l'auteur d'Hébreu
dans Hébreu 12
versets 22 à 29
je vais le lire
et puis le commenter
aussi là dessus
il dit
mais vous vous êtes approché
de la montagne de Sion
de la cité du Dieu vivant
la Jérusalem céleste
des myriades
qui forment le coeur
des anges
de l'assemblée
des premiers-nés
inscrits dans les cieux
du juge
qui est le Dieu de tous
des esprits
des justes
parvenus à la perfection
de Jésus
qui est le médiateur
de la nouvelle alliance
et du sang
de l'aspersion
qui parle mieux
que celui d'Aben
la chose
qu'il y a
où Dieu aussi
était en train
de pointer
la leçon à Israël
c'est qu'à un moment
Israël avait cru
que
parce qu'ils
faisaient des sacrifices
c'est-à-dire
ils étaient
ils rejetaient l'éternel
dans la forme
la plus profonde
d'expression
c'est-à-dire
qu'ils soient
ils l'aiment
de tout leur coeur
leur âme
et leur force
mais ils avaient choisi
d'avoir des coeurs
éloignés de Dieu
mais dans la pratique
d'honorer Dieu
donc ils rendaient
des sacrifices
au Dieu des nations
mais ils offraient
aussi des sacrifices
à Dieu
et ce que Dieu
est en train
de leur reprocher
un moment
c'est qu'ils n'avaient
pas compris
le but pour lequel
Dieu permettait
la loi
c'est qu'Israël
comprenne un moment
qu'ils sont dans
l'incapacité
de pouvoir
accomplir la loi
d'ailleurs même
lorsque Moïse
leur donne cette loi
qu'est-ce que Moïse
leur rappelle
leur dit un moment
mais je sais
que vous allez
désobéir
je sais que vous
n'allez pas
l'accomplir
et parce que
vous allez désobéir
ces jugements
vont venir sur vous
et ils lui ont répondu
non nous allons le faire
nous allons obéir
nous allons le faire
mais Moïse
était en train
de leur pointer
le besoin
c'est-à-dire
de comprendre
pourquoi le Messie
devait venir
voilà pourquoi
comme il leur disait
un moment
il y aura un prophète
qui sera comme moi
écoutez-le
il était en train
d'annoncer le Messie
et il devait comprendre
que sans l'œuvre de Christ
il ne pourrait jamais
trouver la justice
auprès de Dieu
c'était le but aussi
pourquoi Dieu permettait
ce jugement
pour faire comprendre
à Israël
l'incapacité
à respecter la loi
et leur besoin
de comprendre
la promesse de Christ
donc sur cette première partie
déjà
là nous avons lu
Hébreu 12
du verset 22 à 24
il dit
mais vous vous êtes approché
de la montagne de Sion
voilà le contraste
la première fois
ces jugements
sont donnés
sur la montagne
du Sinaï
ces jugements
sont donnés
par rapport à une loi
qu'Israël
est incapable
de respecter
mais là maintenant
l'auteur de Hébreu
dit un moment
pour cette compréhension
vous vous êtes approché
de la montagne de Sion
la montagne de Sion
c'est cette montagne
où Dieu nous accueille
la montagne de Sion
c'est là où
les saints
de l'Ancien Testament
et du Nouveau Testament
donc quand je dis
du Nouveau Testament
nous inclut
l'Église
nous sommes maintenant
réunis
inscrits dans les cieux
nous sommes avec le juge
qui est le dieu de tous
nous sommes maintenant
avec le médiateur
de la nouvelle alliance
et du sang de l'aspersion
qui parle mieux
que celui d'Abel
le sacrifice d'Abel
était juste
mais le sacrifice d'Abel
ne pouvait pas apporter
l'expiation
les sacrifices d'Israël
étaient justes
mais les sacrifices d'Israël
n'apportaient pas
l'expiation
le problème d'Israël
c'est que dans leur idolâtrie
ils avaient pensé
que ces sacrifices
étaient suffisants
pour pouvoir trouver
la faveur de Dieu
ils n'avaient pas compris
que ces sacrifices
pointaient vers Christ
la première leçon
que nous devons garder
à notre esprit
à un moment
c'est de nous souvenir aussi
que nous aussi
nous sommes dans cette incapacité
à pouvoir accomplir
la loi de Dieu
nous serons toujours
dans cette situation
à un moment
Moïse leur dit
vous serez incapables
d'accomplir la loi
là je le dis aussi
à chacun de nous
aucun de nous
n'est capable
d'accomplir la loi
aucun de nous
n'est capable
de respecter
totalement
les commandements
que Dieu
nous a donné
le seul
qui a pu le faire
c'est Dieu
qui s'est fait homme
et c'est le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui a été le médiateur
de cette nouvelle alliance
il a été capable
de le faire
et parce qu'il a été capable
d'être
de pouvoir
accomplir parfaitement
la loi
il est devenu
le médiateur
d'une nouvelle alliance
pour nous
la première leçon
c'est de nous souvenir
de l'évangile
un moment
que
le plaisir
que Dieu va trouver
en nous
ne sera pas trouvé
par nos sacrifices
il sera trouvé
par ce que Christ
a accompli pour nous
nous pouvons faire
des sacrifices
nous pouvons
faire ces choses
mais
ce que nous faisons
n'est que le fruit
du salut en Christ
n'est que la conséquence
de Christ en nous
verset 25
il dit
gardez-vous
de refuser
d'entendre
celui qui parle
car si
ceux-là n'ont pas échappé
qui refusèrent
d'entendre
celui qui publiait
les oracles
sur la terre
combien moins
échapperons-nous
si nous nous détournons
de celui qui parle
du haut des cieux
lui dont la voix
alors
ébranla la terre
et qui maintenant
a fait cette promesse
une fois encore
j'ébranlerai
non seulement la terre
mais aussi le ciel
ces mots indiquent
une fois encore
ces mots
indiquent le changement
des choses
ébranlées
comme étant faites
pour un temps
afin que les choses
inébranlables subsistent
c'est pourquoi
recevons un royaume
inébranlable
montrons notre reconnaissance
en rendant à Dieu
un culte
qu'il soit agréable
avec piété
et avec crainte
car notre Dieu
est aussi un feu dévorant
notre Dieu
Israël
avait refusé
d'écouter
et
Israël avait refusé
d'écouter
parce que Israël
était plongé
dans l'idolâtrie
Dieu nous dit
un moment
gardons-nous
de refuser
d'entendre
celui qui parle
parce que
si nous
nous refusons
d'entendre
celui qui parle
alors même
la création
sera prise
à témoin
contre nous
et il rappelle
un moment
que si Israël
n'a pas échappé
au jugement
en refusant
d'entendre
combien moins
nous allons échapper
au jugement
si nous refusons
d'entendre
le message
de Dieu
au travers
du salut
de Christ
il y a
un sacrifice
une oeuvre
encore plus excellente
que la loi
c'est la nouvelle alliance
qui a été établie
avec Christ
et souvent
nous avons tendance
à juger
les Israélites
en les voyant
incapables
d'accomplir
la loi
et en comprenant
que le jugement
soit tombé
sur eux
mais il n'y a
presque aucune
différence
avec nous
la chose
que nous avons
besoin
de garder
dans nos coeurs
c'est de comprendre
un moment
que notre Dieu
est capable
non seulement
d'ébranler la terre
mais aussi le ciel
nous devons
comprendre
un moment
que toutes ces choses
qui sont ici bas
nous pouvons en faire
des idoles
mais lorsque Dieu
apporte des temps
de désolation
ces idoles
ne nous serviront
à rien
le seul
en qui nous pouvons
placer notre refuge
le seul
qui peut être
un refuge
inébranlable
pour nous
ce sera Dieu
et l'auteur
des brefs
finit là dessus
en disant
c'est pourquoi
recevant un royaume
inébranlable
montrant notre reconnaissance
à Dieu
ce que Israël
n'avait pas su faire
à l'époque
en rendant à Dieu
un culte
qu'il soit agréable
avec piété
avec crainte
car notre Dieu
est aussi un feu
dévorant
et rendre un culte
qui soit agréable
à Dieu
c'est de nous souvenir
de Deutéronome 6
verset 5
tu aimeras l'éternel
ton Dieu
de tout ton coeur
de toute ton âme
de toute ta force
en nous souvenant
un moment
que Dieu l'a accompli
Israël était incapable
d'accomplir cela
parce que leur coeur
n'avait pas été
régénéré
mais Dieu fait cette promesse
je vous ôterai
ce coeur de pierre
et je vous donnerai
un coeur de chair
aujourd'hui
Dieu nous a bénis
avec un coeur
où la parole de Dieu
est inscrite
dans nos coeurs
et là ça veut dire
que le jugement
qui est tombé
sur Israël
alors que la parole
était extérieure
à eux
ce jugement
était terrible
prenons conscience
du jugement
qui arrivera
pour nous
si pour nous
qui avons la parole
de Dieu
qui est inscrite
dans nos coeurs
nous nous permettons
un moment
de ne pas être
cette lumière
que Dieu veut
que nous soyons
pour les nations
Israël avait refusé
d'être cette lumière
Israël a choisi
d'aller adorer
les idoles des nations
au lieu d'être
lumière des nations
aujourd'hui
Dieu nous a établis
comme lumière
des peuples
nous devons faire
attention aussi
à un moment
que nous ne soyons
pas en train
de négliger
le sacrifice
qui a été accompli
par Christ à la croix
et ce sacrifice
va être négligé
si nous sommes
en train de rejeter
alors que la loi
est inscrite
dans nos coeurs
nous sommes en train
de rejeter
le fait d'aimer
l'éternel
de tout notre coeur
de toute notre âme
de toute notre force
c'est Dieu
qui accomplit cela
en nous
mais c'est à nous aussi
comme l'auteur
d'Ebrun le rappelle
c'est à nous
de faire nos efforts
pour rendre à Dieu
un culte qui soit agréable
avec piété
avec crainte
gloire à Dieu
merci